Transcription: Théo Bondolfi
Relecteur: Guillaume Rouy
Si je suis là aujourd’hui devant vous,
c’est grâce à un combat
sans merci pour la vie.
Oui, nous avons combattu,
nos enfants et nous-mêmes.
Nous avons connu ce que signifie ne pas
pouvoir marcher, utiliser nos mains.
Si je suis là aujourd’hui, c’est grâce à
un tournant de vie
qui a fait bifurquer ma vie, passant
d’infirmière à chercheuse
puis d’éducatrice à chercheuse
en sciences de l’éducation.
Il y a eu un long trajet, un long
parcours et j’ai dû apprendre
l’observation, l’observation scientifique.
En effet, dans ma pratique, régulièrement,
je suis confrontée
à des situations très délicates,
voire impossibles.
Régulièrement.
Je dois avouer que très souvent,
je me pose la question : que faire ?
Je travaille
avec six étapes scientifiques.
La première : j’observe, je teste,
je vérifie un petit peu tout,
tout ce qui se passe.
Deux : je pose une hypothèse.
Trois : j’expérimente.
Quatre : je vérifie le résultat.
Cinq : j’interprète les données,
en les comparant, en les analysant.
Six : je dresse une conclusion
ou une nouvelle hypothèse.
Tout ceci en modifiant
ma trajectoire si besoin.
Prenons un exemple concret.
Une femme pénètre dans mon cabinet
attenante à l’école dans notre centre
de santé-éducation.
Ses traits tirés révèlent
une extrême fatigue ;
devant elle, une fillette
de trois ans, épileptique,
se rue sur les jouets mis à disposition.
Vous savez, ce genre d’enfant
qui a dû avaler une pile
dans le ventre de sa mère
qui ne se fatigue jamais,
ni en paroles ni en actions.
La maman la houspille exaspérée
par cette agitation,
motif de la consultation.
En l’écoutant, je récolte mes données.
Tout en observant la petite,
son teint est pâle, ses lèvres pincées,
son ventre ballonné.
Elle prend tous les objets
sans structure, sans attention.
Lors de l’anamnèse,
je suis comme un...
un détective.
Je capte toute information sur la famille,
sur le mode de vie, sur l’éducation,
sur la grossesse, l’accouchement,
tout indice est précieux.
Je remplis avec la maman une liste de
symptômes détaillés
selon les différents systèmes :
digestif, rénal...
Et aussi en notant l'intensité et
la fréquence des symptômes.
Puis, je pratique certains tests
adaptés à la situation.
Pour l’enfant épileptique, par exemple,
je lui ai demandé de suivre du regard
un petit objet que je déplace
afin de vérifier sa convergence des yeux.
Au niveau cognitif, je lui présente
un matériel de notre école,
et observe sa manière de l’utiliser,
tout simplement.
Puis, je pratique un bilan postural,
une observation du corps dans les trois
dimensions de l’espace.
La dernière étape consiste
à l’élaboration d’une grille d’observation
qui me permettra d’observer
et d’objectiver l’observation
et les symptômes de l’enfant
dans son contexte familial.
Elle me permet aussi de faciliter
mon observation,
faciliter aussi les changements
de traitement
tout en ayant ce suivi.
Et les parents, dans cette situation,
avec ce plan, cette grille,
s’impliquent fortement
dans le suivi de leur enfant,
donc ils apprennent cette démarche
scientifique d'observation.
La consultation étant terminée,
je passe aux hypothèses.
Il y a beaucoup de facteurs
et de causes à l’agitation d’un enfant,
seulement physiquement.
Pour cette fillette née par forceps,
je suspecte un problème crânien,
mais il peut y avoir un problème digestif,
un problème d’allergie,
un problème rénal et j’en passe.
Vous savez, dans l’éducation,
on va souvent parler dans ces cas-là
et l’entourage va le dire, de problèmes
psychiques, émotionnels, éducatifs,
voire que l’enfant est vive et pourtant,
dans ma pratique d’infirmière,
je me suis souvent posé des questions
et spécialement celle-ci :
en tant que professionnels de la santé,
qui nous dit que nous ne sommes
pas trop limités pour imposer au patient
le diagnostic psychosomatique ?
Admettons que nous prenions
différents tests,
et même tous les tests,
les examens complets connus aujourd’hui
et qu’un patient se plaint
toujours de douleurs
mais que les examens disent que non,
tout va bien, que la santé
du patient est bonne.
Qui me dit que nos connaissances actuelles
ne sont pas trop limitées
et que ce patient peut être a des soucis
que nous ne connaissons pas aujourd’hui ?
La médecine évolue tous les jours.
Qui nous dit que plus tard,
nous ne retrouverons pas les problèmes ?
Suis-je assez parfaite pour juger
du psychisme de l’autre ?
Non, je ne crois pas.
Toutes ces questions m’ont mise face à moi
même, à mes propres limites,
et m’ont poussé à chercher
de plus en plus loin.
Ce sont les résultats finaux,
ceux des traitements qui m’ont prouvé
que, peut-être, la voie était bonne.
J’ai été même parfois très surprise
de voir de grands progrès et des guérisons
dont je ne m’y attendais pas ;
alors, j’ai continué dans cette voie.
Vous aimeriez savoir ce qui est
advenu de la petite fille?
Non seulement elle s’est apaisée,
mais son épilepsie est
une histoire ancienne depuis plus d’un an.
Le secret de la réussite de ce suivi
dépend premièrement d’une question
que je me pose chaque fois.
Quelles ficelles tirer dans cet
enchevêtrement de nœuds que sont
les symptômes et les problèmes
de santé des patients ?
Pour en dénouer,
mais ne pas en créer d’autres.
Deuxièmement, le secret de la réussite
de ce suivi dépend du plan d’action
mis en place, adapté au bon moment
et surtout accepté par les parents.
Cette collaboration étroite avec eux
comporte un risque, même plusieurs.
En voici un : il arrive que des mamans
enthousiastes par les progrès d’un enfant,
appliquent les traitements
à tous les enfants et à toute la famille.
Et là, nous entrons dans certains
problèmes assez délicats,
surtout lorsqu’il s’agit de nutrition.
Je vais peut-être vous surprendre
en vous disant qu’observer, c’est avoir
le courage de tendre à l’objectivité,
Et de travailler sur un chemin rocailleux.
En effet, l’observation scientifique
met en lumière des indices
dont nous devenons responsables.
Mais que l’entourage n’est pas prêt
forcément à accepter.
Observer scientifiquement,
c’est accepter qu’on vous tourne le dos.
Surtout lorsque l'on est pionnier
dans un domaine.
Car toute vérité passe
par trois étapes, n’est-ce pas?
Elle est ridiculisée, combattue
puis acceptée comme une évidence.
Observer, c’est ne pas emprunter
le regard des autres,
en suivant
une pensée unique, ou formatée,
ou, si vous le voulez, l’esprit mouton.
L’observation scientifique,
c’est revenir aux valeurs d’empathie,
dans une société en crise.
Et c’est surtout de croire
que n’importe qui, enfant ou adulte,
peut sortir de son horizon de barbelés,
de sa souffrance, quelle qu’elle soit,
convaincu que cette dernière peut devenir
une richesse et une force,
aidant nos enfants,
avec beaucoup d’empathie ;
soutenant les parents avec tolérance.
S’arrêter, observer,
sans autre pensée, sans agir, sans parler.
C'est une victoire sur la pensée unique
pour des enfants uniques.